we've already seen that fractions could
be used to represent parts of holes now
we're going to extend that idea a little
bit to think about them as actual
numbers on the number line so let me
draw a number line right over here
so that's my number line let's say that
this is zero
this is one and let's say that this is
two
and let's say i wanted to represent i
want to represent the fraction
let's say i want to represent the
fraction three over four
three over four
so one way to think about it is let's go
between zero and one so this fraction
the numerator here is less than the
denominator so this is going the value
of this is going to be less than 1. so
this is going to be someplace between 0
and 1. and one way we could think about
is divide this section into four equal
spaces
so that would be dividing it into two
equal spaces so if i divide those again
now i've divided the space let me draw
that a little bit neater now i'm
dividing the space between zero and one
into four equal spaces now three-fourths
means that i've gone three out of the
four spaces towards one
so i've gone one two three so this point
right over here on the number line this
is three
over four
this point right over here what do you
think this is going to be
well we've moved one two of the spaces
towards four so this is two
over four and this space right over here
this or this mark right over here on the
number line what is that going to be
well we've moved one of the four spaces
towards one so this is one fourth what
about this one well you could call this
zero fourths which is the same thing as
zero so you normally wouldn't call that
just zero fourths and now we have
another interesting question
what could you also call this base
well we already know based on how we
already marked the number line that this
is a one but using this using the fours
in the denominator we could say hey look
we've moved one two three four out of
four spaces we could call that four
four fourths and that also makes sense
so let me make this clear four
four parts
out of four total parts out of four
parts
equals one whole
equals one
whole but this also makes sense from
what we know of division this little
fraction symbol that we all all we we
keep using this is the same thing as
divided by this is 4 divided by 4 and we
know that any number divided by itself
is except for 0 zero's a little bit
strange
but any non-zero number divided by
itself is going to be one so this could
be viewed as four fourths so let's do a
little ex a few exercises with our
newfound knowledge of fractions on the
number line so let me get a little
exercise going
so
here we have
move the orange dot to 3 6 on the number
line so we already see that they've
divided up the space between zero and
one to three into six equal sections one
two three four five six so we need to
move it to three of those four sections
one
two three
let's check our answer let's do a couple
more of these
move the orange dot to two fourths on
the number line so we have one two three
four equal sections we need to move it
to one
two of them if they didn't divide it
into four equal sections for us then it
wouldn't have been so easy to just count
two it has to be the number of sections
has to be the number in the denominator
and then the number of the numerators
how many of those we move the dot to
let's do one more of this this is a lot
of fun
move the orange dot to one fourth on the
number line well we already did that
when we were drawing it out there's one
two three four equal sections and we are
going to move to 1 4.